for the average person that's having a
hard time with gas i saw this article
here that i don't know if you saw this
or not is inflation ruining your day
just eat lentils and let your pets die
corporations artificially inflating
prices bloomberg bloomberg opinion came
out the other day saying inflation
stinks most if you earn less than 300
000 a year here's how to deal with it
take the bus
don't buy in bulk
try lentils instead of meat nobody said
this would be fun okay
what are your thoughts about some of
these things on how people are handling
the rise of gas prices
well
if they're economically sensitive
they're going to drive less right and
take public transportation
and the politicians are trying to ease
the pain so they're reducing gasoline
taxes when they should be
not doing that uh yeah there's there's
talk about price controls which is
really scary that didn't work for nixon
no no no i hope we don't go in that
direction i mean these oil companies are
coining money no question about it
i'm doing relatively well in the markets
have 20 of my portfolio and energy
and i just tell you look at the numbers
they're powerful powerful well they're
not they're not making stupid
investments anymore well they're afraid
to because they've convinced the public
the administration has but esg
and then it's a sunset industry and they
you know so they're afraid to make
investments so they're returning the
money in the form of dividends and stock
repurchases can't blame them
no but uh you know i believe that this
capless system adjusts and things will
happen you think you think this is uh
we're seeing the the high with gas
prices and inflation or it's still going
to continue the rest of the year i think
it's going to continue until the fed
gets out ahead of things or the price of
energy pushes us into recession i think
we're heading to recession i don't think
in 2022 i think in 2023 is a growing
probability of recession and that will
bring the market down
by how much what are you thinking well
i'm thinking uh if when a recession hits
the mark will have dropped 40 percent
from its high
so the high was 4 800 so that'd be near
3 000
but not this year
that's a pretty that's a big number
right there yeah well it's a big number
but uh we're
see the discussion is just centered
around what is the appropriate multiple
for the market
and i when i consider the degree of
involvement by the government in the
system i say an 18 multiple the s p is a
reasonable number well 18 times 225 230
dollars says the market's fairly valued
at 4 000. the market's been kept in the
overvalued territory by very very
accommodating monetary policy and that's
changing i think powell will be the
first to admit that he made a huge
mistake inflation huge biggest policy
error the fed has ever made
okay absolutely agree
and so i i think that interest rates can
get up to the point where it'll
hit the economy it may take another year
to get there
right now the stock market is benefiting
in to some degree but we're the best
game in town you know they say in the
land of the blind the one iron man is
king or the tallest [ __ ] you don't
want to invest in europe now because
their proximity to russia
china's big questions about rule of law
and fixed income is
totally mispriced
so you know the u.s market wins by
default
as richard fisher used to say the most
attractive horse in the glue factory
okay so i have to think about that one
but this sounds reasonable so we had an
interesting comment and maybe danielle
can give some thoughts on this uh paul
volcker had it right higher rates lower
prices
that's the cure
that is the cure but as lee just said
jay powell missed the window and now
it's going to prove very costly because
he's going to have to channel hopefully
his inner paul volcker paul volcker
purposely put the us economy into
recession in order to get inflation
tamed
and the the economy paid a price and you
have to have somebody with us with the
spine and the constitution to to go that
distance right now because the fed is as
they say so far behind the curve and in
fact senator shelby asked powell
outright in his recent congressional
testimony
can you be volcker and powell answered
him i hope when history is written that
the answer is yes
it remains to be seen you know the fed
is only raised by a quarter of one
percentage point there are 700 basis
points seven full percentage points
behind where they should be in terms of
tightening and that's going to be that's
going to be painful in an interest rate
sensitive economy it is very clear that
powell and the fiscal side of the
economy has elevated societal issues
relative to inflation is a concern
absolutely
just remember every recession sows the
seeds in the next economic recovery and
every economic recovery shows a seizure
next recession he used to have
recessions every four or five years the
last recession we had was 2008 2009.
he's going to try to engineer a soft
landing but my guess is we're so far
from
reality in terms of rates that it's not
going to happen it wouldn't be a bad
thing we've got 20 of us companies are
what they call zombies they can't they
can't service their interest expense so
recessions had been cleansing when they
came around with regularity every four
or five you get the bad players out of
the market well they say a rolling loan
gathers no loss if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]